hi i'm dan sheflin and i'm going to be
talking about our paper optimal
deterministic clock auctions and beyond
this is joint work with jorgos
christodoulou and vasilis godzillas
i'll begin with a brief introduction to
clock auctions and even if you aren't
interested in auctions directly i'll
explain how to think about this class of
auctions as a class of algorithms i'll
then move on to discuss known lower
bounds for deterministic versions of
these algorithms and the matching upper
bound that we propose in this paper
and then i'll talk about how we leverage
randomization in this work to break
through this deterministic lower bound
and finally i'll end the talk with a
really interesting question about
discovering the full power of
randomization in clock auctions
but to motivate the study of this class
of algorithms i'll first introduce some
basic auction notions
so imagine that you're working for an
airline and need to allocate the final
seats on a flight
you have a set of families each of
different sizes each with a number of
seats that they require if they're going
to board the flight
for example the green family has four
people so they need four seats and can't
be served by fewer
whereas the blue family has two people
and needs two seats and can't be served
by fewer
each of these families has a value for
being served and the total social
welfare from serving a set of families
is equal to the sum of the values of the
families in the set
so for example if you were to serve the
green and blue families the social
welfare would be 1050.
and since social welfare is this
additive function over the values you'd
ideally like to serve everyone if you
could
but there's a feasibility constraint
restricting which ones you can serve
in this example let's say there are six
seats remaining on the flight then the
maximal feasible sets are the gray
yellow and blue families the green and
blue families and the green and gray
families
notably as i mentioned these feasible
sets are just the maximal feasible sets
and the feasibility constraint is
downward closed so you could also serve
any subset of these maximal sets
and then naturally we just want to
maximize the social welfare of these of
the families we serve subject to this
feasibility or capacity constraint
and this is the well-known knapsack
problem which is np-hard
and in its own right this is already an
interesting non-trivial problem but this
isn't a problem we study in this work we
examine a strictly more challenging
problem where the values are unknown and
instead the private information of the
customers
so what if we still want to maximize the
social welfare despite this lack of
information
well the standard approach suggested in
the field of algorithmic mechanism
design for this problem is to run an
auction an auction is simply an
algorithm which decides who should be
served and at what prices
and the most standard kind of approach
is the so-called sealed bid format
wherein the participating customers each
submit a report or a bid to the
auctioneer and the auctioneer uses these
bids to ultimately make the service and
price decisions
then the standard objective is to design
well-performing strategy-proof auctions
which means that bidders have no
incentive to misreport their true values
when they submit their bids
and there are indeed many strategy proof
sealed bid auctions proposed in the
literature on mechanism design
but is strategy proofness enough for an
auction to be practical
very often it isn't first of all there
are incentive issues
understanding that an auction is
strategy proof may require parsing a
complicated proof which is often
unreasonable in many scenarios
secondly there are issues related to
trust
even if you understood the proof of
strategy proofness seal bid auctions
require the bidders to trust that the
auctioneer is following the auction
protocol that she claims to be and that
the auctioneer has done all her
computations correctly
and finally there are privacy concerns
bidders must report their true values to
the auctioneer which could reveal
possible sensitive information
and all of these doubts and questions
make the sealed bid format less
practically appealing in many scenarios
so can we change the auction format to
address this
an alternative auction format often used
in practice is called a clock auction
in contrast to the sealed bid auction
format where customers report their
costs their values directly to the
auctioneer in a clock auction the
customers face clock prices that weekly
increase over time and they can drop out
whenever these prices get too high
to see an example of using our plane
ticket scenario let's say the auctioneer
starts with a price of 100
for all customers
the prices could raise uniformly but
need not
because since the prices are not per
ticket they're rather the cost of being
served since the green family is the
most restrictive since they need four
seats it probably makes sense to raise
their clock faster than the other
families
and as i mentioned at some point in the
auction the price offered to some
customer will become too high in other
words more than their private value
in this example this has happened for
the yellow family but then since the
prices are weakly increasing they can
easily verify that they're never going
to want to pay the price ever again so
they can permanently reject the offer
and exit the auction
and this auction will continue causing
more customers to exit as gray does now
until we're left with a feasible set in
this case since blue and green can be
served simultaneously the auction
terminates and their charge their most
recently accepted clock offer 350 for
blue and 550 for green
cloth auctions are desirable to use in
practice because they address the issues
with sealed bid auctions we mentioned
before we have
better incentive properties since clock
auctions are not just strategy proof but
are obviously strategy proof
you simply compare the asking price to
your value and you exit when the price
gets too high clock cultures are also
group strategy proof meaning that
they're robust to coalitions of
strategic bidders all working together
clock auctions also don't require any
trust in the auctioneer they're totally
transparent and credible and finally
clock auctions offer privacy since the
winning customers never have to reveal
their true values to the auctioneer
and while i don't have time to present
them fully all of these notions here
have formal theoretical definitions and
one can prove that if you want all of
these properties
you need to design a clock auction as
this combination of properties is unique
to them
and finally from an algorithmic design
perspective clock auctions are more
restrictive but they do offer a clear
path to designing practical options
simply design the price trajectories but
this itself is an interesting
algorithmic question
in each round how do you choose which
prices to increase
and that brings us to our central
question
if we look at clock auctions as
approximation algorithms what are the
worst case guarantees we can achieve
so let's try to answer this question by
turning towards the design of
deterministic clock auctions i'll first
talk about the known lower bound and
then i'll talk about our auction and
this work which matches this bound
but first let me take a few moments to
formally define the setting
we have a set n of n bitters
and each bitter has a value vi greater
than equal to zero for being served
then we say that the social welfare of
some set as we said before is just the
sum of the values of the bidders in that
set
but of course as we saw in our
flight example there's a feasibility
constraint dictating this collection of
sets that can be served
simultaneously and
this feasibility constraint f is
downward closed right which means that
if s is in f then t is an f for all t
that's a subset of s
and this downward closed feasibility
constraint
actually captures many different natural
scenarios right this knapsack constraint
like in our flight example before where
we have a capacity constraint and
bidders have a size that they need for
being served
or
the well-known combinatorial
single-minded uh single-minded bitters
in a combinatorial auction where there
are m heterogeneous items and bidders
each want some bundle of items and two
bitters conflict if they overlap on some
item right
and since f is downward closed f is
uniquely defined by its maximal sets um
so we'll say that there are k of these
maximal sets
regardless we'll say that the optimal
set o
uh
is just the set of highest social
welfare and we'll say that it has size
little o and we'll denote this optimal
social welfare opt
then we can say that an auction achieves
an alpha approximation if it serves some
set whose social welfare is within an
alpha factor of opt
and while we focus on value and social
welfare here
also important in auctions is the
payments that the bidders have um the
prices that they have to pay um
which is p i for bitter i
and then we say that the revenue of a
set s is just the sum of the prices
so initial results which studied the
performance of deterministic clock
auctions were quite pessimistic
simple examples showed a lower a
logarithmic lower bound in terms of the
number of bitters n on the performance
of clock auctions and we'll see how
simple this is shortly
but since it was so simple for all we
knew complex instances could show even
worse in approximability
but our main result is that the simple
lower bound is in fact tight
we design a deterministic clock auction
which we call the water filling clock
auction
which achieves a log o approximation to
the social welfare for any instance with
a downward closed feasibility constraint
and since the size of the optimal set o
is weakly less than the number of
bidders n we obtain a tight guarantee
but then also looking beyond this we
take first steps toward understanding
the use of randomization and clock
auctions and design a randomized clock
auction that breaks through the
logarithmic lower bound for a wide
family of instances which generalize the
one that give this deterministic and
approximability result
so before we see our auction
let's take a high level look at the
deterministic lower bound to get a sense
of what can go wrong in a clock auction
and what we'll have to deal with in the
design of deterministic clock options
this initial result is due to doing
itself in rough garden in ec 2014 paper
and they provided a really simple
scenario
where there are n minus one individual
bidders who each want one seat on our
plane
uh and one grey family of bidders
that are one grade family uh consisting
of n minus one people who need n minus
one seats on the plane and we just have
n minus one seats remaining in other
words we can serve in any combination of
the individual bidders we like but if we
want to serve the gray family we can
only serve the great family
and i want to point out just again how
simple this is
there are only two maximal sets the
decision is almost trivial you serve the
entirety of the individuals or the gray
family
and even though it's so simple duding
itself in rough garden showed that clock
auctions can't even really perform well
on this instance because if the gray
family has a relatively high value we
can't push their clock any further
before we have to push the clock prices
of the individual bidders
and if these if these individual bidders
have value that forms this harmonic
shape for example
as we raise the clocks of these
individuals to try to learn the social
welfare they'll drop out one at a time
and will never realize their high total
social welfare
and this lower bound shows the central
challenge in designing clock auctions we
can't gauge the total value of a set
without necessarily losing bidders along
the way
indeed the deterministic auction we
propose achieves a logarithmic
approximation on this instance and it
essentially follows the natural scheme
where we increase clocks of low price
bidders not contained in a current best
looking set
however beyond this instance it again
provides a logarithmic approximation for
any downward closed feasibility
constraint so let's take a look at it
a high level our water filling clock
auction which is inspired by the
doubling auction of bavaya tall in each
round computes the set of the highest
revenue given the current clock prices
and increases the clock prices of all of
the lowest priced bidders outside this
current max rev best set
it then continues this process until all
remaining bidders are feasible
let's simulate this on the following
instance with 11 bidders
and where each colored box corresponds
to a maximal feasible set of bitters
in other words the feasibility
constraint is such that if a group of
bitters are all contained in some box
together you can accept them
simultaneously
so if we knew these values
we could obtain the optimal value of 15
obtained by serving the blue boxed set
but of course we don't see these values
in a clock auction
so let's say we start with all the
bidders at some low price let's say one
in each round we'll keep track of the
set producing the best current revenue
max rev which is just the set with the
highest sum of current clock prices of
active bidders
in other words since unlike in a sealed
bid auction we don't see the true values
and all we see are the recently accepted
prices
we'll use some black box algorithm to
maximize the revenue in each round and
since uh the bidder's most recently
accepted price is a lower bound on her
value the revenue is a lower bound on
the welfare we obtain
in this case metric is 4 and it's
produced by the blue set
so we increment the prices of all the
bidders outside of blue with the current
minimum price
in this way we're slowly raising a water
level price that all active bidders
outside the current winning set must
weakly exceed
bidders will drop out if their price
offer exceeds their value and then we'll
proceed to the next round in this case
the revenue is six produced by the
orange set
and we increment the prices of all
minimum priced bidders outside of the
orange set note that these bidders in
this case are all contained only in the
blue box since they were the only
bidders below the previous water level
of two
and i want to highlight nature that in
each round this max rev is
non-decreasing and this is really
important to our analysis
and it's quite easy to see
the key is that we only update prices
outside the current winning set so in
each round we're securing the current
revenue from the winning set
since we always have the option to keep
this winning set the same between two
consecutive rounds we always have this
revenue monotonicity within our auction
that is the revenue earned by the water
filling clock auction is always this
weekly increasing function and in this
case it's eight and it's produced by
blue and now i'm going to fast forward a
bit through a few rounds until we get to
a next interesting round but you can
notice that this revenue is always
monotone increasing
so just going a little bit further
i want to pause here and call attention
to the fact that the bitter in the
intersection of the two remaining sets
will never have her price increased
again since she's always going to be
contained in one of the two winning sets
either the green or the blue
and this follows our natural intuition
right this is how an auction should look
at this point we'll know that we're
always able to accept this bitter in the
intersection regardless of whether or
not we choose blue or green and since
she's in both sets
raising her price doesn't actually help
us distinguish which of these two sets
is better all it does is risks that
she's going to depart the auction which
will just cause us to lose revenue
so i'm going to fast forward again a
little bit further until we hit the end
of the auction where all remaining
bidders are in a single feasible set
in this case we'll serve these bidders
at their most recently accepted prices
of six and three respectively
and the bulk of our paper shows that the
water filling clock auction obtains a
four log o approximation to the social
optimal social welfare for any downward
close feasibility constraint where again
remember that o is the size of the
optimal feasible set um
and moreover if computing the optimal
revenue in each round is hard our
auction also works even only given
access to an alpha approximate algorithm
for uh computing the revenue word
instead we'll achieve a four alpha logo
approximation
and at a high level
we prove these two things by leveraging
the well-known fact that the best
revenue obtainable by offering all of
the bidders in sunset the same price
would yield revenue that's within a
logarithmic factor of the welfare in
that
set through a carefully chosen invariant
we then demonstrate that because the
water filling clock auction always holds
aside the set with the best current
revenue and then approximately sweeps
through all of these uniform prices by
only increasing the lowest priced
bidders outside this winning set the
welfare that the water filling clock
auction obtains is close to or exceeds
the uniform price revenue for all sets
and this is what gives us this sort of
approximation guarantee
so let's now think moving beyond
determinism because we have an optimal
deterministic clock option at this point
but what about randomness
and i want to pause on a question that
is interesting and
fundamental how should one even use
randomization in deciding what prices to
raise
right in this class of algorithms how do
we use randomness
it's not obvious how to leverage the
feasibility constraint and the price
history to choose the right approach
we suggest a simple and natural way in
this paper to use randomization and
provide an auction that we call the
hedging auction which gives improved
guarantees in terms of the number of
maximal feasible sets k
the hedging auction obtains the better
of a log o and a square root log k
approximation to the optimal social
welfare for any downward closed
feasibility constraint f
and since the family of uh
lo the since the lower bound family is
comprises disjoint maximal sets we have
that this parameter k is less than n so
we obtain a square root log n bound for
this family breaking the logarithmic
barrier for it on the other hand
we view this result as only the first
step towards understanding randomization
and clock auctions because the best
known lower bounds against randomized
clock options are just small constants
so how do we obtain this first improved
result
well one natural way to use
randomization that has had applications
elsewhere in mechanism design literature
is to just randomly sample half of the
bitters
so suppose in our instance before where
we saw
the water filling clock auction we flip
a coin independently for each bitter and
for the bitters which we get a heads
which we're marked in green here these
bitters are discarded
but we learn their value
if this sample is representative of the
social welfare in each set
then choosing to serve the remaining
bidders in that set with the highest
sample welfare should work
slightly more precisely if each set has
roughly half of its welfare sampled and
half of its welfare unsampled then
picking the set with the highest sample
welfare should give us near optimal
social welfare from the remaining
unsampled payers right so in this case
remember the optimal social welfare was
15 and we would obtain seven
and i'll note that we can do this
sampling procedure by using a randomized
clock auction by sampling uh by raising
the clock prices of the bidders that we
choose to sample until they reject their
most recent offer
so we've seen that or we've discussed
that if the
value is sort of distributed in each set
between the sample and unsample roughly
evenly the sampling auction can work
well but it's not too hard to construct
instances where this is just never going
to be the case so what if instead of
these values the bidders instead had
these values
we definitely want to serve the gray set
here right it's
huge compared to everything else
but if we sample the bottom left bitter
we're going to lose her value
on the other hand if we don't sample the
bottom left bitter the gray set isn't
going to look like it has very high
welfare at all and we won't choose it
so the sampling auction can perform very
poorly essentially giving no
approximation guarantee if the welfare
in some set is highly concentrated on a
few bitters
so we then propose a different option
which we call the hedging auction and
it's based on the idea that the water
filling auction and the sampling options
are complementary
we mentioned that the sampling auction
can perform poorly when the bidders in
some or the value in some set are
concentrated on a small number of
bidders but when does the wfca water
filling clock auction perform poorly
it fails essentially in the opposite
cases when welfare
isn't concentrated on a small number of
bitters right we have this harmonic
instance from the lower bound
but then the sampling auction should do
reasonably well on this kind of instance
and indeed the hedging auction which
runs either the water filling clock
auction with probability one half or the
sampling auction with probability
one-half gives improved approximation
guarantees
giving a sub-logarithmic approximation
for generalizations of the deterministic
lower bound instances where since the
maximal sets are again disjoint k is no
more than n
also in recent work with michael feldman
and nick gravin we show that a tighter
analysis of this hedging auction
actually gives a log log k approximation
which implies that an exponential
improvement on this family of
deterministic lower bound instances
so in the last few moments i just want
to wrap up with a brief reminder of our
main results and a question that we just
think is totally fascinating
we first give a deterministic clock
auction that is asymptotically optimal
with respect to the size of the optimal
set for any downward closed feasibility
constraint
and we take a first step towards
understanding the use of randomization
in the design of clock auctions by
proposing a really natural way to
leverage randomization that ends up
giving better approximation guarantees
for a wide class of instances
but this does leave a natural open
question
what approximations can be achieved with
randomized clock options
even for general downward flow settings
the best lower bounds we have are small
constants
so for all we know a randomized clock
auction may indeed give a constant
approximation for any downward closed
setting this would just be an amazing
result if true
and that's all i have thanks for
listening